des soldats Ukrainiens s'élancent au
cœur d'un écran de fumée une tactique de
déception
pour extraire des camarades blessés
c'est en tout cas l'idée derrière cette
session d'entraînement au nord de
l'Ukraine mais aujourd'hui aucun tiret à
la faveur des fêtes qui entourent le
Nouvel An cette unité de défense
territoriale ne souhaite pas provoquer
ses voisins
la frontière biélorus c'est juste à côté
ce n'est pas toujours aussi calme il y a
150 000 soldats postés juste de l'autre
côté ils sont à kilomètres
la Russie a transféré au nord de
l'Ukraine des troupes battues sur
d'autres fronts depuis la fin octobre
alors les forces ukrainiennes se
préparent
une stratégie de diversion pour attirer
nos forces principales dans une mauvaise
direction
et à ce moment là il pourrait essayer
d'attaquer ailleurs mais la seule chose
qui les attend ici c'est la mort
pour se mettre en travers de la route
des troupes russes mais des citoyens
comme zitla sont surnom de guerre se
sont engagés en masse
je n'avais pas d'expérience militaire
nous étions tous des civils et n'avions
jamais tenu une arme avant les choses
ont changé drastiquement de campement de
fortune au cœur des marécages et des
forêts leur unité a sorti de terre des
positions faites pour durer tout l'hiver
et bien au-delà
vivre 24 heures sur 24 les uns avec les
autres a fait deux une famille
la semaine prochaine on se fait une
course de 10 km 10 km elle est ou 10 km
à les retours
les attendent à la maison beaucoup ne
les ont pas vu depuis plusieurs mois
seul une ligne téléphonique unique et
sécurisée leur permet de rester en
contact
on utilise très peu d'applications la
géolocalisation est interdite le
téléphone c'est pour parler pas pour
jouer on échange avec nos familles et
c'est tout
la tension des troupes est aujourd'hui
maximale alors qu'approche le premier
anniversaire de la guerre ils essaient
toujours de faire quelque chose au-delà
de symbolique je suis sûr à 100% que le
24 février il y aura une sorte de
provocation à 100%, est-ce qu'ils
envisagent une invasion à grande échelle
ou pas il y aura certainement une
provocation
les troupes ukrainiennes au nord sont
certaines qu'elles verront de l'action
bien assez tôt